thank you so yeah
it says
okay so this is this is uh based on uh
collaborations with uh
uh some students at ut austin anagal
who's here and srinam uh
and mahesh who's uh my former student
now at google
okay this is part two
now part one involved this problem that
we call regenerating codes uh
and uh part two has three subparts so uh
we'll talk about locality which is the
concept that was introduced before and
two extensions of the concept of
locality that that we call availability
and then another related thing that's
called the batch codes
okay so repair problem as we have
discussed is you have uh
a code uh you lose one symbol you want
to recreate it and you have this
newcomer node that connects to the
existing nodes
the repair is recreating a single array
symbol at a new location as we have as
we have said and the most important
thing to take is you know the repair
problem is a new important problem that
was a the highest level bit that we are
really realizing now
uh and in the previous tutorial we
focused on repair bandwidth which is how
much communication do you need to
reconstruct one erased symbol
now an interesting thing that is not
that well known
is that in regenerating codes the way
the way the model is set up
this newcomer has to be able to
reconstruct by connecting to any d of
the surviving nodes
uh
so a relaxation of that is okay you lose
something you don't have to reconstruct
by connecting to any d maybe thus there
is one set of the nodes that you recon
that you talk to when you reconstruct so
if you if you if you change the game in
this way
you you have a much easier problem you
have much more flexibility and this this
flexibility has not been fully
understood in terms of how much it
benefits you in repair communication
it definitely will help you in the
second metric that it will allow you to
make d
smaller than k
because if you were trying to if you
were sticking with your generating code
framework and you said i want this node
to talk to fewer than k nodes
then you you can quickly show that
that's impossible to to recover by
connecting to any d but if you fix the
sets as we will see in a second you can
do
that uh so we're going to relax this
concept now and we're going to focus on
okay and now the set of nodes that the
newcomer talks to it will be called the
repair group
okay now let's go back to basics for a
second minimum distance okay so the
distance of the code the way i i think
about it one way is the minimum number
of failures after which you lose data
okay so that's one way of thinking about
uh minimum distance
uh the classic single bound that
everybody knows is that this is the best
you can hope for
uh
in terms of distance for an nk code and
of course read solomon codes achieve the
the singleton bound and they're called
maximum distance separable because of
that
now what is now going to define the new
concept uh i guess the same one that
works to define is called locality so
locality so a symbol has locality r
if it it's a function of r other symbols
so we'll call this other our other
symbols that you can read and recreate
that thing a repair group for that
symbol okay
now if we talk about systematic codes uh
we can say that all the message symbols
or the systematic symbols have locality
are that's a reasonable thing to ask for
and if you are more strict you can
further ask that the parities have
locality are okay
so all symbol locality means that both
systematic symbols and the parities have
small locality which means have small
groups
uh yeah
if code is linear
it's not the same so let me i'll show
you an example right now
so let's see so you have ten systematic
symbols
and you add four read solomon varieties
this is this in particular exactly this
structure is the code that was used in
uh the facebook analytics cluster a ten
plus four read solomon okay
so this thing is a linear equation of
all these ten symbols and it's a dense
linear equation you can easily show that
if if this is going to be an mds code
each of those linear equations must
involve all the systematic symbols okay
so it's a dense linear equation that
involves all 10. so you start with erit
solomon but this doesn't have any
locality now because if you lose one
thing let's say you lose this you have
to read 10. in fact you can eat any 10
but that's trivial locality local decay
so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to take the first five
extort them maybe together or make a
linear combination and create what we
call a local parity that's just the xor
of those and now you can obviously see
that if i lose any one thing here i can
read the other things and the xor and
reconstruct okay so that's an extremely
simple way of understanding what a local
repair group is there's a more
complicated way to to enforce these
local constraints
through algebra and that's that's what
for example tom and uh tamo and bark do
but i think of it this way just
exploring things it's the easiest i
think
so of course it you lose some you lose
some things in in the field size but
that's okay so we accord these things
now we extort these things and we get
locality for these but now if i lose a
parity i don't have locality right i
still have to read 10. but maybe
maybe you could choose these
coefficients
so that let's say for example that this
parity was the simply the xor of all 10
okay if it was the xorfall 10 then if i
lose this even though it doesn't look
like it has locality it does do you see
that alex why can't you just x or these
four
xoxo
these two
so if
oh yeah i can exactly and i will yes
very good so one thing i can do and i
will do it in a second is add another
local parity on the parities
and get locality on the parties the
penalty i pay is
my rate went down a little bit right
because i added a new symbol that i have
to store
just like before very good but but the
interesting thing i'm telling you now
that's a that's a little different is i
can get locality in the parity sometimes
that is not obvious if i mess with the
algebra right
because imagine that this was just the
xor of all 10 and that this is the xor
of the first five and this is the xor of
the other five now i i have locality for
this but it's not obvious because if i
lose it i can read this and this right
so sometimes i can get locality in a
non-obvious way if i mess with the
algebra but now my equations are not in
what's called in general position
so i will lose in fall tolerance if i do
that so the the tension that we're
trying to understand is how do we how do
we get the
best trade-off in fault tolerance versus
uh
locality okay
so in this case of course all the
message symbols can be recovered by
reading five other symbols and a single
parity requires still 10 reads unless
there's some non-trivial linear
dependency that i haven't encoded in
this in this picture okay
now the question you can ask is what's
the best distance possible for a code of
locality r which means
what is the the the sets what are the
sets of failures that you can definitely
recover okay
so okay so let's so let's let's start so
i'm going to do this thing that i enjoy
very much i'm going to write on the
slide so let's say i lose this
and this
yeah i hear
i hear there's a
there's something linked to my salary
directly for that
so can i tolerate four failures okay can
i tolerate any four failures can you how
first of all if i lose these local
things no problem i can reconstruct them
from from the source okay so if i lose
these four
six seven eight nine can i reconstruct
them
why
so i have the global parities right the
global parities are are wild cards right
they're linear equal so they can replace
any four okay so another another
observation here okay so i've never i
didn't use the local parities at all i
have enough power just from the global
okay so these are easy situations so now
a situation that perhaps is not okay now
how do we make this go oh we do it like
that okay
so now what if i delete this
i delete this and i delete all the
parties here
can i recover from this set of failures
so i have the local parity that is
helping me to recover this and and now i
have all the data and now i will okay
now the thing i guess the smallest case
where it gets interesting is this
can i reconstruct recover from this set
of failures
no
was it six okay
so okay so let's let's think a little
bit what's the best distance you could
ever hope to have okay so the best
distance if these were global equations
right that's the best thing that could
happen theoretically well then i have
four and i have two i could have two
more global equations so i could i could
hope to get any six right so that but
but that would be mds but um as i'm
going to show
it's it's not possible to get mds that
that's that's that's the main result
that
yeah
but but you see you could be doing some
things where
this this thing
and this thing combined could produce
another global parity it could be it
solomon parity that you created where
you took the coefficients of that read
solomon parity and you would you do what
it's called splitting which means what
what we had before you remember there
was one one one one one on one we took
the first five ones put them here the
second five ones put them here so when
you add them you create a global party
this is the idea i guess that starts
from the pyramid codes paper where you
create the local things so that when
they are added they give you a global
thing again
so that is sort of the one of the
explicit ideas we have and other ones
just make random combinations but in
this case you cannot you cannot tolerate
these kinds of failures so that's a
question that that that people
we're investigating starting with with
uh the gopalatal paper
so
um okay let's let's do a warm-up in an
mds code all symbols have locality k
that's uh let me see i'm doing one time
here okay
uh all symbols have what what time i
started five play ten late
yeah so you started at about ten pounds
so we can add about 12. okay
you have you have equipment to stop me
although you are hitting lunchtime so
yeah i understand
your
vision yeah yeah okay
so let's let's start with two easy
pieces first one uh in an mds code all
the symbols have locality at most k okay
so that's trivial because mds code k
symbols give you everything so of course
if you read any k in fact you can
reconstruct any one okay it's trivial
statement okay
now this is
also very simple in an mds code
uh must have trivial locality for every
symbol so i claim that if you have any
any smaller locality you lost mds okay
how do i prove that
well uh
is the statement clear first of all okay
now how do i prove that well if i have
some non-trivial locality so let's say i
have a group that involves two
systematic symbols and a parity
in the linear code it's easiest this is
a generator matrix and i told you that
when you add these two columns you get
this column right so this is a
non-trivial
linear dependency now an mds code means
that any k by k some matrix must be full
rank but if you choose this these three
together you have already lost rank so
you have you got already uh non-mds and
the proof uh so the
okay so any non-trivial locality creates
a linear dependency and this creates
loss of rank
uh
okay so the main result is that codes
with all symbol locality can have
distance at most as much so this is the
result by gopala natal that that has
gotten a lot of attention recently it
looks like singleton bound but but it
generalizes a single bound right
so it was shown initially for scalar
linear codes and we were able to
basically repeat the same proof they had
but instead of rank do it with entropy
so we were able to show that this is
true even if you vectorize the code so
you deal with sub packets and further
more even if you did non-linear things
with with the bits
so and and the argument by the way there
is proof at least the so actually talks
about three proofs i guess the the one
that the way the way that i think about
it is you have an adversary that is
trying to collect as many columns as
possible from this matrix or as many
symbols as possible but on the other
hand he's trying to keep his entropy low
so the moment so he's greedily choosing
so he's going to choose one column and
choose another column and now he can get
this column for free because it's a
linear dependency so he puts columns in
the bag in this greedy way and the
question is how many columns can he put
until he must have rank r
and that's exactly how you get this so
and then in in our proof you replace
rank with entropy and it's the same
argument basically
so this is how this is proven
uh and of course if you set trivial
locality or equals k you recover a
singleton bound
and you also get this interesting
message that if you want any non-trivial
locality in your code you will have to
pay you you will lose in fault tolerance
of the code
in in exactly this way
and
initially the the question of course is
okay can we achieve this right are there
codes that match this uh bound
have this distance and um pyramid codes
uh
achieve actually is bound for message
locality and the idea was
start with a big
red solomon and split the parities so
you split them so that they have the
localities you want but this doesn't
work for all symbols so if you want also
to repair the parities and in general
there was a lot of work trying to
construct explicit codes for this
uh i think the the state of the art is
is the ta'amu embargo result which does
it with polynomial filters linear field
size
okay all symbol localities so how do we
get all symbol locality we need to add
exactly what you said so so we add the
parity on the parities like this
and the power we have here of course is
we choose these coefficients that are
forming these linear equations and
depending on how we choose them that's
that's sort of the non-trivial part of
this the the combinatorial structure of
of lrcs is
and you can prove that it's kind of
trivial you partition the things and you
you just make one one protection
xor for each or one protection line
equation for each and that's the best
you can do
okay so the coefficients in the in the
local groups must be in what's called in
general position so general position
means that there are some linear
dependencies that you cannot avoid just
by the structure of this picture
any other linear dependency must not be
there right so the question is we don't
have a general tool
to create
linear equations in general position
except to the best of my understanding
except
making a a
very big field and choosing everything
randomly
saying okay i need all these
determinants to be on zero multiply them
together i need this big determinant to
be on zero and do smart develop on that
but that requires an exponential field
size we don't have a deterministic
deterministic or polynomial field size
way of doing that solving
uh general position linear equation
but but uh the tom and bald paper
does achieve this in a very nice way
uh
by i guess generalizing with solomon uh
but it doesn't do it doesn't tolerate
all the patterns that are correctable
the problem yes please
so so you're saying that if for example
like you said earlier p1 is x1 xor x2
yeah
it's good in the sense that um it's easy
to reconstruct if you lose some of those
but it's actually bad because you have
worse false fault tolerance yes so you
want to avoid that
it depends it depends if you want if it
depends right so sometimes you want
locality for if you want locality for
the parities
you have to pay for it either by
creating a parity on the parities or by
making this the xor of these two
but then you will why do you lose in
fault and i don't know if that's obvious
to you but one way that you can
immediately see it is
i could you can imagine that these two
together if both of them survive the
failure pattern i could xor them and get
another parity that was p5
right so they could you can always think
of these as potentially giving me
another global parity that could be
useful in some patterns right
so that's why there's a tension between
creating linear dependencies that will
give you locality and linear
independence will give you fall
tolerance right so that's that's what
this is about
okay
good okay
so uh
very good so the thumbnail construction
does it with polynomial field size but
it doesn't tolerate all the failure
patterns that are potentially
collectible
and and this was a very interesting open
problem that we talked about that's
called maximally recoverable codes we
don't have a way of of creating these
things basically creating
linear equations in general position
yeah of course okay so we can definitely
do it with with uh smart simple argument
but with with polynomial field sites
yeah or explicitly in fact
and explicitly a lot for lrcs a lot of
constructions like the silverstein your
construction right right
they do have mmr but but uh
for lrc's you can get
right right right yeah the polynomial
field sizes yeah very good
okay so there is uh yes i guess i i
mentioned some recent work here another
natural thing you can do is you can put
the log you can make the local codes a
little stronger right so you can say oh
i want any two failures in this group to
be able to tolerate them with locality
so you can add the second you can make a
little solomon on these five symbols at
the second local parity here
and that's that's uh related to these
works here that you can get locally paid
for multiple failures within a group
and the explicit electricity
consumptions we talked about and another
interesting piece of recent work is okay
how do i get a locality bound
essentially this equation
what happens to this equation if i limit
the field size right
so this has been a
interesting recent work
by mazumdaran kandambe on obtaining
distance bounds if you for a fixed
field
okay
so next part unless there are questions
other questions here
okay cool
next part is uh this is a fun video
observe
uh
you got all of them
so
multiple reads with one code so that's a
concept we call availability
so we said locality means a symbol is a
function of r other symbols
availability t
is the following thing i i want to do
not just be able to read one thing by
reading a few other things i want to be
able to read it by reading it by adding
a few other things many times in
parallel
okay so i want many disjoint repair
groups
for for one symbol
uh so that's the concept of availability
uh and these theories have locality are
if each one involves up to our symbols
of course so these are small repair
groups
example
so i have this code this is my
systematic symbols my read solomon
global parities i i keep this local xor
and i add another xor where i sort one
and six and i get this and i xor
uh what do i do
okay that's fine so this is just a
little code
so
i have the boss
and the boss wants to read block one so
he goes and does the systematic read
but now that he does the systematically
this this symbol is busy right and all
this the server that is storing this
this packet is busy
and now you have wally
so wally also wants to read symbol one
but he can't read it systematically
because the server is busy serving
another job
so he can read it in parallel by reading
by using this repair group right two
three four five nx one and he reads
those and extorts them together and he
gets a parallel read and now all these
servers are busy and now you have dog
bird
and dog bird also wants to read symbol
one
and she can read it in parallel using
the other repair group six and x2 xor
them together right so that's why this
is a useful thing when you have and you
often have data that is called hot data
where you have multiple jobs
concurrently trying to read it you want
disjoint repair groups that are spread
across your servers so you can support
multiple concurrent jobs
okay
so block one can be read by one
systematic plus two repair rates
simultaneously so we say block one has
availability two with groups of locality
five because this group this group has
locality five
and the second group has locality two
and notice that there are other groups
right so there's for example another
group you could use since you have this
global
linear equation you could read 2 3 4 5 6
7 10 and p1 and reconstruct but that
would be a terrible idea because you
would be blocking all the other groups
right
so now the combinatorics become
interesting because
you you have to design these groups so
that they're not blocking each other too
much
and also it's not trivial even after you
have designed the code
after you get a
something you want to read which groups
to select so that they're not blocked
together
okay
so uh so it rt information local code
has t disjoint repair groups for its
symbol
and you can also limit if you want the
size of the repair groups to be r
in fact you don't sometimes you don't
even have to do that because if you want
many parallel groups they have to be
small just so they can be disjoint right
okay so what you used to call rt
availability arc availability is this is
different from rt information
yeah so so information local means okay
so this is this is ankit's uh
yeah buzzwords that i may have may be
using here so okay so
so the first one is t disjoint repair
groups and also
i want each one to have locality r now
this is only for the systematic
for the parities you can ask for just
locality so that's what ankit was
calling uh i think he calls it rt
availability
yeah so yeah
it doesn't matter it's just
yeah yeah so it's it's i i always would
say it with i will describe what it
means because i'm also confused with
yeah okay so basically you know we for
every symbol you can have it's how many
groups and how big are the groups right
so we understand okay
now for example free replication
it gives you
every symbol you can read it in parallel
three times obviously
and uh the distance of the code is bad
it's and the rate of the code that's the
most important is terrible because as
you want to increase the availability
your rate goes to zero like like one
over the the number of times you repeat
the data
so
the the locality of these reads is great
because of course the local repair
groups for one have the best locality
possible one they're just copies of the
block so the locality is great but the
rate is terrible
so the main question that that we were
interested in is is it possible to keep
the rate constant
so so that doesn't vanish to zero but
have scaling number of of parallel reads
right
uh so
that that was the main question that we
were thinking about
uh
scaling a little bit with non-vanishing
rate okay why is the availability
instead of three
because for some reason we decided not
to include the systematic read in the
count which every time i read my papers
again i'm tempted to define it the other
way but then the other benefit is the
availability is the number of repair
groups
also so the systematically it doesn't
count as a repair so yeah it's because
of that okay
so uh now the question the first
question that we are asking is
what if you want some uh locality r and
some availability t what's the best
distance you can get right so
generalizing the the gopala natal bound
if you force many groups
the short answer is
we have a bound but it has a star
and the star is quite a big star
because it has a lot of dirty details
under which we can prove this this bomb
so the first one
which is not a big deal i think is that
this bound for the best distance for a
given code with uh availability iron
sorry with locality iron availability
only holds in this in this case we only
prove it for scalar linear codes i don't
think this is a very big deal it
probably holds for non-linear too more
importantly
i'm sorry
this this is the ceiling
ah sorry okay so so what is scalar means
okay what is the question what's
non-scalar so all the codes i had
all the co all the classical codes you
ever see are scalar uh what i did before
in my previous lecture was i took a
symbol and i i sliced it up into half
symbols
and i was doing linear algebra in half
symbols so you can vectorize symbols and
do send half symbols and stuff like that
and as you this is extremely useful in
all the storage coding work so it's very
reasonable to ask before you ask for
nonlinear code say okay maybe there is a
way to represent with subpackets so you
have a linear code over
sub-packetization
so that's that's what non-scalar means
okay
uh now but so this this result we cannot
prove it currently for non-scalar i
believe it is true
but what is more important is we make
this assumption we assume that only one
parity uh
so every repair group can involve only
one part of the symbol so that's a very
restrictive structure and you may be
able to do better if you if you allow
more complicated parity structure
uh and and we don't know if what what
happens if you also want to have a
availability for the parities so if you
want all symbol development
in some cases we can achieve this bound
using objects called combinatorial
designs
furthermore specifically resolvable
combinatorial designs and there's a
concurrent work by tamon bark that gives
a different bound for minimum distance
for a code with locality
uh rn availability
t
which to the best of my understanding is
incomparable to our bounds sometimes our
bound is tighter and sometimes this this
airbound is tighter so this is uh quite
a wide open space to
to generalize the gopala metal bound if
we also force many repair groups
okay is it clear
uh a very i just want to very quickly
say a few things about how we create
codes with availability so combinatorial
designs i i don't i don't want to get
too much into this but just i'll just
say fun fun fact so it's a way to to
group to group symbols into groups so
that the sizes of the groups are fixed
and every symbol appears in c subsets of
the regular
and you have this important property
that any two symbols appear in exactly
one subset or block as they call them
this is similar to expansion expansions
say that the neighborhoods are not
overlapping too much
combinatorial designs fix exactly how
much the neighborhoods overlap which is
not needed by the way but this is just
one way that that we create codes here
so
the other thing that is interesting is
something is called resolvable designs
resolvable means that your your groups
if you if you set them they form a full
partition of your symbols
so this is resolvable combinatorial
designs and a famous example that's kind
of a fun problem is this one
you have 15 girls who will walk in
groups of three each day of the week
the problem was how to place them in
groups of three so that no two of them
worked together uh twice right so this
is
monday you know tuesday and you see one
and two walked together so they're never
allowed to walk together ever again
this problem has a fun story probably
more fun than the problem itself
because
kaylee proposed the solution and
sylvester said that oh you stole my
solution all that so there's a fun story
about this in in wikipedia
uh
and you know right now there's a field
in combinatorics of how to design these
things for a given sets of parameters
which involve of course the size of the
groups
and how much uh you know the the number
of the groups and all these parameters
for some cases there are explicit
constructions and we use those
the interesting thing i want to say here
is this so in those days
what's that yeah
yeah which which would be good i guess
we can apply this to a design of a
workshop right exactly yeah so it can be
no two researchers spend
spend more than once
exactly
exactly very good so that's that's the
interesting thing i want to say thank
you so what is resolvable resolvable
says
that i can partition so the resolvable
in this case means that uh
you know the everyday all the girls are
are walking right that's what it means
here in in the code it means that i will
take a global parity
and i will split it and this will be my
reservable design so resolvability
ensures that you can create the local
groups
by splitting global groups
so it has the extra benefit that you can
do it by splitting as opposed to random
linear combinations that's why i need
the resolvability really otherwise if
you just make random accommodations you
can just do it with combinatorial
designs
okay
so the using these uh
designs
uh
we are able to get uh polynomial
availability
specifically we can support n to the one
third concurrent reads of one symbol
and the size of each one of them is
almost 10 to the one-third and this of
course builds on specific combinatorial
designs that that we leverage to create
the codes and these are reservable so we
can generate them explicitly using the
pyramid code splitting idea so this is
the the best construction we have
uh so you can say this is pretty good
right because you can support n to the
one third parallel reads of any one
symbol it's quite quite surprising
and the fundamental bounds is of course
for a given locality and availability
what's the best distance possible
our bound is tight sometimes but most of
the time it's actually really way off so
how much time do i have now
20.
okay very good
okay so this is uh the isi 2014 paper
and also in preparation
ah i want to say something that i will
talk about more later
and many people here know more about
this than i do so there's something
called smooth codes which to the best of
my understanding means that there's a
linear number of groups
and that they don't overlap too much
right so which is which is very similar
to what what i was asking before
but typically in smooth codes as far as
i understand the number of the groups is
linear which makes this problem very
very hard typically i was not asking for
a linear but you know even even
something like a poly would be with a
small exponent would make me very happy
of course typically i think these don't
have distance a good distance but you
can also improve the distance by adding
some global parities at the end if you
want to so that's not a very big deal
now batch codes is the other related
concept that i want to talk about in the
in the third part
so asking for more so if you google
greedy on google images you get this
image which is fun image of a 3d person
so
the first thing we asked was we want one
small repair group for each symbol right
so that's called locality then we said
oh you know what i want many disjoint
repair groups for its symbol that's like
availability
now the thing that that we can further
ask
is we can now with availability we can
support multiple parallel reads for one
symbol
but maybe you don't just want to read
one symbol a thousand times maybe
sometimes you want to read
one symbol 50 and another symbol 20
another symbol three right so maybe you
want to support
any set
of t reads
okay so possibly the same thing or two
things or three things or any number of
symbols so there's something called
multi-set batch codes
that were defined for a different reason
in cryptography i guess or the main
application cryptography but also a
storage application that that's a little
different but you can easily see that a
multi-set batch code can support a
multi-set of t parallel reads
so that means for example you can have t
parallel reads of one symbol which is
exactly the same thing as availability
but furthermore
you could have
t over two concurrent reads of any two
symbols
or by the way this is not concurrent
right so it's not t of one and this so
it's either t of one or t over two of
some two
or
t reads concurrently of different
symbols so any such situation any multi
set of reads you can accommodate okay
this is very nice because now when you
design your storage system or your or
your scheduler you get all this
flexibility any t things will happen
concurrently for you
so this is very nice requirement the
question is can you can you get codes
that do it
and already in the first paper on batch
codes there is a construction that that
does pretty well uh
so this is what you get if you google
batch codes on and google image
google images batch this is probably
some product and they call these
like these secret batches of
products so anyway i don't know exactly
what that means
now batch codes um
allow multiset of t parallel reads and
there's a very interesting connection
uh to smooth code that is already
recognized in the original batch code
paper so it says if you have a really
good smooth code
you can massage it and create a very
good multiset batch code from that
so
from the connection of these two things
and what i'm going to say here is some
that i haven't seen written somewhere so
we're working on it so this is current
work that we're doing now with anna and
some students at ut so i i'm not sure if
i worked this out correctly also i
changed notation at 4 00 a.m yesterday
when i was going south so
i think that this is what you get you
can support an amazing almost linear
number of parallel leads
with rate approaching one which is
great right
if you if you combine this this
construction which to my understanding
is one of the state of the art for uh
smooth codes with getting a batch code
from a smooth code
now what i'm going to show you in the 15
minutes that i have left
is a much much much easier i think
combinatorial way of getting this so i'm
going to get
n to the one third almost so this is
worse than this because i this is almost
linear so a little significantly worse
in the number of parallel reads i can do
but still polynomial
but i'm going to get a better rate so
i'm going to get the rate approaching
one polynomially fast
and
furthermore i can do this with a
deterministic decoding algorithm while
this is randomized and the the proof is
graph theoretic
and yes
for that for that first one do you say
that
the uh
your availability t is linear
almost
no not only availability it's even
stronger right it's any any any any t
reads so not just theories of one thing
yeah but if if it's uh so is that little
o of one yeah but it could be like one
right
and then
t is n to the one minus one or n to the
zero or yeah yeah but but this is this
is vanishing as this little of one is is
vanishing as as the code is growing so
yeah
alexa now the locality you're content
with locality like end to the epsilon is
that
what's that so the locality now so
you're not worrying about locality i'm
not no yes but the locality is is going
to be some poli
yeah yeah yeah
something like that yeah so of course of
course this is enforcing locality right
because the groups have to be small to
be discharged yeah
yes very good so the the and the other
thing is i can do this proof for you in
10 minutes okay so it's actually
extremely simple
i think
almost so let's see the distance of
these codes is bad the distance is bad
but okay so so in our construction the
one we're writing now we're making the
distance uh
approach
uh singleton also so we can get
excellent distance but the way we get it
is little putting a little hat on top
you just add some global parities yeah
and you can always do that as long as
your rate is super good
so that's why that's why you need the
rate to be super good because then you
can add a little bit of extra global
parities to get the global fault
tolerance
okay
now let's understand how all this works
so this is like if you have if you
haven't understood anything you can
reboot now and
start again 10 minutes
very simple combinatorial problem okay
what's the combinatorial problem
i am putting k
symbol systematic symbols here and these
are just xors for now okay just
extruding stuff okay
now every symbol has degree t okay so he
participates in t xors
and now this xor is the xor of a with c
okay so this is a local repair group for
this of course because you can read c
and this xor and reconstruct a okay
all right so i claim that if this graph
has no four cycles then each information
symbol has t disjoint repair groups
that's my claim is this obvious
you see it let's see it
okay so this is a this is a repair group
the green repair group okay and this is
another repair group for simulate the
red repair group
what does it mean that they are
disjoined it means that that this guy's
children and these guys children do not
touch right well if they touch there
would be a four cycle and that's all i'm
saying
okay very simple thing
yes you're not using the right hand the
right hand side does not have to use
degree two but it's just okay so so the
right hand side the degree here is the
locality of each group right the size of
the group
so i'm i haven't explicitly
forced it but i want their children to
be disjoined so they can't have too many
children right yeah
cool okay
so
enough for cycles means that the groups
are disjoint that's easy
but but uh okay so to maximize the
availability now what do you want well
you want to have a few of those because
these are parities they make your rate
go down
so you want few right notes but also you
are forced here to have a lot of degree
here you want a lot of legs leaving each
one of those vertices so these are
things are intention
because you cannot have any four cycle
so this is a combinatorial question
right how can you make a graph that has
few girls a lot of boys and you want all
the boys to know
a lot of girls at the same time people
in combinatorics of course have looked
at this extremal graph uh construction
and we use that
right so that's fine i will give some
reference later but but there's an
interesting thing to give you batch
codes batch codes means that i can also
read different symbols right so
for example this guy and this guy
have one repair group that they share so
it's not you cannot use this group
concurrently but that did not form any
cycles right
so
so how do you deal with with cycles when
you want to be able to accommodate any t
reads
not just from one thing
okay
so the key interaction lemma that i have
here is that if this graph so before i
was asking no four cycles now i'm going
to ask girth eight which means no four
cycles and no six cycles right
so i'm going to say if this graph has
girth eight
and how am i doing on time i have ten
10 10 good okay people are almost awake
still so good
so
if this graph has girth eight and left
degree at least t
then the following things happen the
first thing is that any systematic
symbol has t disjoined repair groups why
is this true well this is the same as
before right so gear fade means no for
cycle already okay
now further for any pair
of of systematic symbols
uh if if uh any one of their disjoint
groups
of x i has common symbols with at most
one of the repair groups of xj which
means
you can block at most one every time
so that's that's the the key local
argument why is this true well you just
to do a few cases and you see that if
this is not true you will get a six
cycle or a four cycle so the the proof
is like one very very simple proof
actually you just say okay if they
overlap this way there's a four cycle
otherwise there's a six cycle so that's
that's basically the local argument
now if you have this local argument you
can support any t parallel reads
because the way you do it is you say
okay choose one symbol it has its t
options
now you want to do another one you know
that it will not not at most one will be
blocked from each one of them and you
keep going in a greedy way to construct
getting a bound on how many things are
blocked in each step this is a very very
simple greedy way to construct
which groups to use since you know what
how much blockage there can be so it's a
very simple proof
is it clear any questions
okay
so
so basically now we just need a way
to construct graphs with with few
uh right
vertices as high degree as possible and
no four cycles and no no six cycles so
this is some of the works that that will
leverage in in the paper that we're
writing right now
in particular i think this is probably
the the one that gives us the
the best construction right so the
the the one that well when i think is
the one that that gives us the best
asymptotics
uh and basically it gives us what i
claimed before
n to the one third uh
a parallel arbitrary reads with rate
approaching one polynomially fast
okay so this is the
the end of the talk conclusion open
problems
which repair metric to optimize
well we said you can repair
communication or locality or
availability or a combination
so the answer i think is it depends from
the practical side so if you have a
cloud server or an analytics server or a
photo storage server there's different
these things matter
differently so it's a complicated
world and to have a real impact i think
you have to talk to the people who
really do these things
and like you know you can say this is
the best car or maybe this is the best
car or maybe this is the best car but of
course depends you know where you want
to go and in the in reality the this is
what you will end up having in a
in a real system i think
so something combines everything in
a way like that so open problems
for repair bandwidth what is the exact
repair bandwidth region of course is
open
practical exact msr codes for high rates
are open as we discussed
repairing with a finite field limit is
open
and repairing reed solomon for example
is open going back to vancouver's
question yesterday i i thought a little
bit about the asymptotics
the the trivial construction reads k
symbols communicates k symbols to repair
one
uh
the theory says it could drop down to
constant asymptotically because the
regenerating codes bound gives you as so
fix the rate to any constant you want
and grow in
uh regenerating codes give you uh so it
will look like this
so
so the trivial thing is k
so it doesn't change
as you increase k and you fix
the so this is the msr point
you right
uh okay
and the thing that we have is basically
just a constant away from this
so
so this is constant and this is
approaching a constant here so there's a
ridiculous embarrassing gap for it
solomon and i don't know where the truth
lies
okay
oh it won't go
okay so if i do this maybe it will go
okay good nice
uh locality so what is explicit lrcs
with uh mr the problem that works it
also said this is very interesting
ah this is also a very interesting
question so separatization as we said
means splitting into subpackets and
doing network coding locally before
communicating
we saw that this helps
in regenerating codes does it help in
codes with locality or does it help for
example you can ask even in the ldc
context
does it reduce communication
to do some local combinations of sub
symbols and send some symbols
uh when you when you're asking for an
ldc or for a
for a locally repairable code so i don't
have it i don't have an example where it
helps
and it could help in communication right
so that's an interesting question even
an example for this i please send me if
you find one
for availability what's the trade-off
for distance of course is open and
practical codes are open
another open problem that i have is the
girth argument that i just presented
gives you batch codes
and smooth codes give you batch codes
but i don't know how batch codes can
give you smooth codes maybe there is a
simple argument but i'm not 100 sure
my big high level open question here is
can you use simple girth arguments like
the ones i said to obtain
ldcs or smooth codes
and then you can just do graph theory
instead so i don't know
and of course in terms of applicability
i think that all these questions are
applicable to hot
data which means data that's frequently
accessed and there's actually a recent
paper on uh
by facebook
that uses some sort of an lrc
construction for their photo storage
cluster so there's a lot of practical
questions that you can ask and
implement these systems in real search
so i will stop here
wow you finished before
yeah terrific yeah
all right any more questions for alex
yeah just one comment about the girth
arguments producing smooth things that
is
so much like the original uh distant
things the theme
expanders are known to give some kind of
smooth forms yeah right the same regime
as this
ksy so i'm not fully
understanding uh how expansion and girth
so girth girth is an easier thing than
expansion right so
yeah so you assume expanders it's more
gives you more power so using that there
is a paper which gets uh ldcs i see same
as this case and that's just uses
combinator just a combinator
some sort of tanner like construction
locally used some smooth coats which you
have to find by some mechanism
in a big expander i see
i see but i guess the benefit of girth
over expansion and this this we used in
ldpcs also is girth you can check in
poly time and right so that that that
would be very nice if you can get with
girls but i see
okay we have no more questions thanks so
much alex for coming here
thank you